all right let's do something fun so
you're on a deserted island which
Grantchester colleague of yours would
you take along okay okay I think when
you're standing on an island you don't
want to be bullied you want to be the
bully who's gonna beat it if you're not
on an island you're already bored and
you seem that there's no hope then you
see an ish then you see there is some
hope here you can get out of there
that's the motivation to get out of
there if I can say okay Manish at least
I don't have to talk I just turn them
all on then I sit back and chill
I guess Magnus because his is physically
strong because build things okay let it
let it be Magnus so he looks at this
like I believe some Vikings were his
professorship I would prefer to be by
myself
I'm guessing if I depict someone I'd
probably say ding simply because he's
just mostly doc it's very hard since
nobody speak Chinese all right let's do
another one who would you want to go to
dinner with all right
the vichy if I had to pick somebody just
cuz of all the stories he's had from
playing for so long and just playing
against people from different generation
so he definitely the most stories and
that would make for the most interesting
person to eat dinner with we shall
Magnus ending there was a pretty
interesting personalities and I would
love to have a serious conversation with
them okay let's say this which is
extremely interesting person he's
extremely experienced in life and mini
chess and their enemies are they're all
very nice person - Chuck - I guess wish
it because he was very educated and he's
always a pleasure to talk to you can
learn from him Levon is fun to be with
and also busy but either one of those
okay probably Aronian he's a foodie so
you know I don't have to worry about
ordering the food or something and he's
really good I think you have to get my
wife the most jealous if you take this
seriously it's fishy because I've had
many dinners with V chef at a great time
but if you don't take this serious I'll
say Magnus I wanna be there in this
awkward silence and just watch him
suffer what the hell am I doing here I'm
gonna watch him and make him suffer and
he be like I think I don't know I think
let's have some coffee or tea here you
want some dessert no no I do want some
dessert they're excellent cheesecake in
this place you sure that I didn't have
two words I'd like hit a tee you know
didn't it felt like it was hours ago
let's just start all over and you know
you're gonna take awhile there yeah when
I'm watching suffer
you